(crowd cheering)
- Earlier this month,
New York saw record rain fall
as the remnants of Hurricane
Ida swept through the city.
The storm shut down most of the Big Apple,
including the airports, the subway,
but not, it turns out
one woman's dating life.
This is Cassidy.
- When you accidentally go on
a first date in a hurricane
because you feel bad
canceling last minute.
And he wants to go.
- I'm just saying, if I don't find love
with this kind of effort,
well then. Who will?
To the date which was one single hour long
in which he made me pay for myself.
When I checked we're
in a little hurricane,
we walked outside and he said,
"yeah, you're right, we
should have rescheduled."
No man on earth has ever
made a woman this wet.
- Zero out of ten. Do not
recommend going on a date
in a tornado/ hurricane.
- And we're back on the couch
where I wanted to be
the whole night anyway,
with a margarita. Cheers
to dating in New York City.
(Cassidy chuckles)
- We have Cassidy here now.
Give it on for Cassidy.
Well meet Glen.
- Hey, nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- Um okay.
I was dying to show Glen that video.
He had not seen it and I had
so much fun watching it over
and over last night.
But before we talk about that video,
tell us more about yourself.
- So I am 25. I live in
New York City obviously.
I'm a fitness instructor
and I'm also pursuing a
career in musical theater.
- [Kelly] Awesome.
- I had no clue that that
video was gonna blow up
the way it did. I had like 300
followers maybe before that.
And it was just so silly.
Like obviously that journey,
I was like, this is ridiculous.
I have to document this,
dating in New York is so crazy.
- Oh my God. Well, especially
if you're in a hurricane.
(crowd laughing)
I was like, wait, and then
you think maybe this guy
will be fun, if he's willing
to risk going through hurr-.
Yeah.
- That's what I'm saying.
- Yeah. You thought, yeah.
And then he made you
pay, which he made you,
he asked you out, like you
have to go out on the date.
- Yes, yes.
- And he makes you pay.
- And you, like look at. (laughing)
- I know.
- It's so bad.
- It's wild, I know.
- Outrageous.
- Dating does suck. I
was like, what happened?
This must have been the worst
date you've ever been on.
Right?
- Definitely makes the top 3.
- Wait what?
- New York dating, like
I said, it's crazy.
- Wait, what's a bad one?
- All right, for example.
There was a guy who I
went on a first date with,
who wore like a straw Dapper
Dan's like bowler hat,
like a quartet hat on and
refuse to take it off.
It was like a joke. He
was like, it's funny.
I was like, oh yes, it's funny.
But you can take it off.
And then he brought me to
the bar that he works at
so we could get free drinks.
Then he ditched me for his brother
who also worked at the bar.
- He left you? Like in
what, just left and...
- The brother also worked at the bar.
So he basically just was like hanging out
with his brother there.
I know, sad.
- What! What a jack hole.
- People are just crazy.
- Oh my God. I don't
know if you can say that
or I don't even know if
that's a term either.
Wait, any advice for Cassidy?
Like with...
(crowd clapping)
- I mean, you don't know until you show up
that they're a tool.
- Again, if it's a blind
date, yeah, you have no idea.
If you've got some
interaction with that person,
and you've got some sort of
a like vibe of that per...
I found that like, when you meet someone,
whatever that feeling is
that you get from that person
is probably right.
You know what I mean?
So like, if you meet somebody
who's like charming and really,
really handsome, right?.
And you're like, "oh,
he's charming and handsome
but I don't, I'm not buying it."
Like, it feels like an act.
It's an act. It's definitely an act.
- Oh.
You see the red flags, huh?
- Oh yeah. I see them.
I see them right away.
- Okay.
- Like immediately.
- Well, don't brag about it.
(crowd laughing)
Um, so I have a solution for Cassidy.
We've done this a couple of times before
and it was enlightening.
Backstage, I have two
guys ready to meet her.
(Cassidy chuckles)
(crowd woos)
- I'm just saying, are
you down to meet them?
- Absolutely.
- I mean, here's the
thing, you never know.
- Well hold on. Do they have money?
(Kelly laughs)
- Do they have any money at all?
- They have a job, just a job.
- Just wondering.
- Am I gonna pay for the
date, is the question.
You should ask that.
Okay, there is a catch though.
As a judge on The Voice
I'm used to listening
without seeing the person.
It really does make a difference.
So Cassidy this time,
you're just gonna use your ears
and I have something that will help.
(royal fanfare)
(crowd cheering)
So, we're gonna help her learn
how to choose the right guy
by changing her technique.
Instead of seeing her potential suitors,
she'll have to use her ears and her heart.
Get it?
This is Blind Dating.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
Are you nervous?
- A little, but bring it on.
- But do you feel, isn't
it a powerful chair?
Do you feel powerful?
- I feel very powerful.
- Exactly.
- I'm ready.
- Yeah, like if you were
the helm of like Star Trek.
- (Glen) That's what I was thinking.
Yeah Star Trek, very Star Trek.
- Bring out the guys.
- All right.
Let's meet the guys.
You'll be happy to know
they both live in New York.
So there's that.
- Woo!
(crowd cheering)
- Welcome guys.
All right, so,
they are both very cute.
Just so you know.
So bachelors, go ahead
and introduce yourselves.
Matt, you can go first.
- What's up guys? What's
up Kelly, Glen, Cassidy.
I'm Matt. I am 30 years old,
originally from San Diego.
I'm a bartender at a cocktail
bar in the west village
and I am an extremely
active athletic individual.
I love sports and I have a
really strong relationship
with my mom.
She's really...
- Okay, mom card.
- The most important woman in my life,
and I just, I love her very
much. We talk almost every day.
- That's so cool. Oh my God,
I hope my son's like that.
I hope my son does that.
Okay. Eric, how about you?
- Hey y'all. Hey Kelly.
Hey Glen. Hi Cassidy.
My name is Eric.
- I heard that "y'all",
- Y'all, shout out, Kelly.
I just moved to this city
about three months ago
from Austin, Texas, where
I work at a tech startup.
- Yes!
(crowd cheering)
- I'm getting used to the
whole lifestyle of New York.
Like I say, excuse me,
and please and stuff,
even though they bumped
into me or something,
I'm a really into watching
sports, playing sports,
but at the same time,
I love like reality TV,
like The Bachelor and Love Island.
- I love you.
- So, I get really into
like Fantasy Football,
but also like Bachelor in
Paradise Fantasy. I do them both.
- Okay. Awesome. All right.
Well here's how this works,
Eric and Matt will take turns talking.
Just like The Voice if Cassidy
hears something she likes,
she'll hit the button, the chair will turn
and that will be the man that she chooses.
Now Cassidy can hit
the button at any time,
but I strongly recommend
patience and really listening.
'Cause no one can block you here.
So any last minute advice for
Cassidy before we get started?
- Trust your gut.
- Okay.
I don't know if that's gonna help, Glen.
(group laughing)
All right, Matt and Eric,
what's your idea of the
perfect first date in New York?
Matt, we'll start with you.
- A perfect first date would be probably
we would actually start off playing
some mini golf, big, big golfer.
So, get some friendly
competition going on.
I like a little competition
and we'd do that on the Hudson.
And then we'd take bikes to one
of my favorite cocktail bars
in the village.
And then we go to one of
my favorite jazz lounges
and listen to some good music,
and they have some pool and
shuffleboard and ping pong.
So we kind of keep the friendly
competition thing going.
- All right, competitive.
- Okay.
- Eric, how about you?
- Cass, if it's all right,
I'm pretty new to the city.
So I'm kind of exploring myself.
So I think our ideal
first day would be like,
explore the city with you.
Maybe go to a deli, grab a
bagel, which I'm not too used to.
I'm more in the breakfast taco scene.
- Amen. Hallelujah.
- And then grab a coffee
and walk throughout like
Central Park or whatnot.
I do know of one spot in Dumbo, Brooklyn,
which has a nice view
and skyline of the city,
which I'm not used to in Austin.
So I'd probably end the
night there with you.
- Awesome, awesome. Thoughts,
what are your thoughts?
- I'd go out with either
of these guys honestly.
- Either of these gentlemen.
- You know, if I went that way,
I would definitely, yeah.
These guys are a catch.
- All right. Let's take things up a notch.
You know, I believe in the magic of song
and this is my voice chair.
So I asked Eric and Matt to pin
their very own love ballads,
even if they didn't want to.
So hit it guys.
(charming music)
♪ Oh Cassidy, when you went
on this date, you had hope, ♪
♪ but the rain washed it away. ♪
- ♪ Cassidy I know my singing is vile, ♪
♪ but I hope time with me
will make it all worthwhile. ♪
♪ I heard your TikTok blew
up and it was really funny, ♪
♪ but I promise every day with
me will always be sunny. ♪
♪ I promise you, take my hand
and you'll never walk alone. ♪
♪ Through the rain, sleet or
snow. I'll be there with you ♪
♪ Closer to your heart ♪
- All right!
♪ I heard he made you pay
and walk over a mile. ♪
♪ In water 3 feet deep like
you're crossing the Nile. ♪
♪ I bet you wish you never
went, the jokes on him ♪
♪ because you're hanging
out with Kelly Clarkson. ♪
♪ I know you want somebody to
give you some commitments. ♪
(Kelly screaming)
(crowd clapping)
- Wait!
I was enjoying the music Cassidy.
So, okay you chose Matt.
So come over, y'all meet
each other. Okay. Okay.
And a big thank you to
Eric, our Texas man.
(crowd cheering)